PRODUCERS HAS COME UP WITH.
>> THE HOT DOG HAT BACK ON.
>> YES.
>> AS IF THAT IS NOT ENOUGH.
WE ARE NOT DONE.
>> WE ARE NOT DONE?
>> YOU HAVE TO COME WITH ME.
HERE WE GO.
>> EVERYBODY.
>> EVERYBODY, IT MEANS
EVERYBODY.
>> WHERE ARE WE GOING?
>> WHEREVER THE GOD FATHER TELL
US TO GO.
>> WE HAVE TO FINISH THIS OFF.
IN THE WAY, THE ONLY WAY WE
POSSIBLY CAN.
>> I THINK I KNOW WHAT IS GOING
ON.
>> HERE IT IS.
>> CHUCKSTER, I GOT THE KEYS,
THEY ARE YOURS.
YOU ARE THE BUS DRIVER.
>> WE ARE DONE WITH THE SHOW
TONIGHT.
YOU CAN TAKE US HOME.
>> IT IS THE CHUCK WAGON!
YES, WE DO HAVE A BUS.
>> Y'ALL HAVE NOTHING ELSE TO
DO.
>> I AM GOING TO GET DIRECTIONS.
OH, LORD.
SERIOUSLY.
>> YOU GETTING ON THE BUS?
>> YES.
>> WE ARE ON THE BUS.
>> THE DOOR IS OPEN.
>> MAN, IT SOUNDS LIKE HE HAS
EXPERIENCE HERE.
>> CHUCK.
>> I DON'T WANT TO BE ON THIS
BUS.
>> SHAQ, LET'S GO.
>> COME ON, SHAQ, GET N.
>> YOU HAVE BEEN A BUS RIDER
BEFORE.
>> YOU RODE THE BUS.
>> HERE HE COMES.
>> WEARING THE HOT DOG HAT.
>> THE HORN DON'T WORK.
>> HERE WE GO.
>> TELL THEM TO OPEN THE GATE.
>> DON'T WORRY ABOUT THE GATE.
YOU CAN TAKE IT OUT.
>> DON'T TAKE THE GATE OUT.
>> Y HE CAN.
>> HERE WE GO.
YES, HE CAN.
>> FOR SHAQ, KENNY AND THE B